-Welcome back to the show.
I appreciate
every time you come.
-I've always wanted
to drink water here.
[ Laughter ]
You always see, like, the cup
but I don't ever see
anybody drink.
And I always wanted to just have
a little sip of water.
-Yeah.
I have to ask you,
because we talked about this
last time.
You now have a house.
-Yes.
-And last time we talked,
you thought --
you had an ice maker
and you thought
the Three Stooges
were burglaring your house.
And it made me laugh.
But you have a house.
How is it?
And I heard that Questlove
helped you decide
to move Upstate?
-That's true. He did.
I was looking for a house,
and I was looking
out in some town
that I shouldn't have been in.
[ Light laughter ]
And he was like, "You
need to look where I'm at."
And I looked up there,
and it's quite nice.
I do enjoy it.
It's good water.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not used to having
neighbors, though.
Like, even still, I've never
seen you before,
like, in the neighborhood.
-i have yet to move in.
[ Laughter ]
-So you sent me
to a neighborhood
that you don't even live in?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm not ready yet.
I'm not ready yet.
-Yeah, so I'm, like,
the guinea pig
for the neighborhood, now?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you like it?
-It's crazy, though.
Like, when I first got there,
some lady, like,
brought me bread.
[ Light laughter ]
She knocked on the door
and was like,
"I'm your neighbor.
Here's some bread."
-That's so nice.
-Trying to poison me
or something.
-No, Upstate,
that's not what they do.
-If you're watching this, ma'am,
I punted your bread
over two fences.
[ Laughter ]
-You're too paranoid.
She was being neighborly.
-No, man,
I've lived in apartments
in New York City my whole life.
I've never met one neighbor.
[ Laughter ]
Not one person.
We don't make eye contact.
We're nice people that way.
Suburbs, I don't trust it.
-I want to ask about Colin Jost,
your "Weekend Update" co-anchor.
You guys are fantastic together,
by the way.
Congrats on a great season.
-Oh, stop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He just had a baby.
-That's true.
Well, Scarlett did.
-Scarlett had the baby, yeah.
Have you met the baby?
-I have, man.
What a cute kid.
But babies are --
they're fun for, like, a second.
[ Laughter ]
You know, they don't do much
after you've looked at them.
And they're just staring at you,
trying to
keep their head on straight.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Get this wiggly thing
away from me.
But, no, it's, like,
an adorable baby.
It's Colin and Scarlett's baby
together.
-Are you going to babysit?
Has he asked you yet?
-I don't like babysitting, man.
I'm actually a really good
babysitter, though,
if you guys are interested.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm a great babysitter.
I've been babysitting
my whole life.
I have nieces and nephews
that's like
three years younger than me.
-Oh, really?
-I've been babysitting them
since they were babies.
Since I was a baby, actually.
-Yeah,
Were you a good babysitter?
-I was a great babysitter, man.
I just let you cry
until you're sleepy.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, "Michael Che:
Shame the Devil."
This is your stand-up special
on Netflix.
-I'm excited.
You know, right about now,
I just feel like
what the world needs is
more stand-up comedy on Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
Something that everyone
can agree on.
-Yeah, yeah.
I love the name
"Shame the Devil."
I've never heard that term
before.
-Never? You don't got,
like, a black aunt?
[ Laughter ]
"Shame the Devil" is a very --
it's something that, you know,
like, church ladies say.
They say, "Tell the truth,
shame the devil,
'cause the devil is a liar."
No one has ever heard this
before?
-No, I mean, I haven't.
-The Roots are shaking their
head, "Yes, absolutely."
[ Laughter ]
"Shame the devil."
-So, you're just kind of
just telling the truth?
-I'm trying to.
But as much as I can, you know.
-Yeah, you're a great comic,
man.
-Let's not...
-Where did you film it?
-In Oakland.
Oakland, California.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A lot of Oakland fans here.
What's it like backstage
when you're on the road?
Do you have a rider?
Do you have --
What do you have in the room?
-I'm fascinated with riders.
Like, I don't really
have a rider.
I usually just ask for, like,
chicken fingers and M&M's
because that's just
my life right now.
But I'm fascinated
with other people's riders.
Like, I'm always like --
Anytime there's a performer,
like, before me, I'm like,
"What did they have
in their rider?"
And then, like, they tell me.
Like, some performers --
one comedian --
I won't say his name,
but he asked for,
like, white sneakers
before every show.
Brand-new white sneakers.
They got to buy them
before every show.
-Can you do that?
-Apparently, yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Isn't that the coolest thing?
You do it, too?
-i do it with T-shirts
and other things.
But I like to provide
my own shoes.
-That's awesome!
-Wait, do you go do a gig
and you have them buy you --
-I mean, you have a rider.
It's, you know, part of
the terms of agreement.
-No, I understand
what a rider is.
-So you put the sneakers
on the rider,
and then, you know --'
-They got to do it.
-Yeah, mission accomplished.
[ Light laughter ]
-One less thing
you got to think about.
My favorite rider thing
was Snoop Dogg.
I was doing a gig,
and Snoop Dogg was there,
like, the week before me.
And it was in the U.K.,
and I was like,
"Man, what does Snoop Dogg have
in his rider?"
He said, "Regular stuff, but he
ordered 150 pounds of chicken."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"150 pounds of chicken?"
It blew my mind.
For, like, a whole year,
I'm thinking, "Snoop Dogg
eats more chicken
than anybody on the planet."
[ Laughter ]
And then I was telling a friend
about it.
I was like, "You know Snoop Dogg
asks for 150 pounds of chicken
in the U.K.?"
And she was like,
"Money or weight?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. That makes more sense.
-Yeah, apparently,
he doesn't eat a barrel of
chicken before shows.
-Where does he put it all?
He's got good metabolism, man.
-It made the story
a lot less interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show a clip.
If you guys needed a laugh,
you got to watch this.
Here's Michael Che
in "Shame the Devil" on Netflix.
Take a look.
-Black people
love this country.
We're just more specific
about our love.
You ask any [Bleep],
"You love America?"
he's like, "I love Brooklyn."
[ Laughter ]
"Atlanta is cool.
I don't know [Bleep]
about them Dakotas."
[ Laughter ]
If there was
a black American flag,
there'd be like 11 stars.
[ Laughter ]
For cities.
It wouldn't even be
the whole state.
They'd be like, "Alright,
Detroit, Oakland, D.C."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everything else would be
a big-ass question mark.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Michael Che, everybody!.
[ Cheers and applause ]
His special "Shame the Devil"
premieres on Netflix,
November 16th.